[Music]
we're here at Santa Monica beach today
it's gorgeous day I've got my man Mike
chain here with me Mike is the most
subscribed fitness trainer on YouTube
pretty popular guy Mike a lot of guys
are making some huge mistakes when it
comes to parting that back and getting
the defined six-pack ABS everybody wants
today I'm gonna show you some of the
mistakes that you're making how to
correct them and a awesome fat burning
workout get some chisel six-pack I'm
excited I need to get more chiseled
myself so let's go get into it let's do
it
we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got CrossFit white-eyed surf set
cardio mission in boot camp it's your
body
this is fighting all right man so the
first exercise we're gonna be doing is
by high knees
so it goes like this 1 2 3 4 5
down her feet jump up one two three four
five just like that so the second
exercise
in and out pushup this is going to work
your chest shoulders triceps so you
start off with about a standard pushup
now
then we're gonna put in some cardio
jumping knee tucks this is one of my
favorites yeah your stay like this
jump tucking your knees just like that
if real estate business
we're doing some abs
hands on your mat feet together it
slipped up like
this is really good for your lower abs
then the next exercise is for your life
total body fat burning workout right a
jump lunge with the squats
so you'll lunge lunge squat lunge lunge
squat so then we don't get any chicken
legs the last one man is called a towel
roll
you hold a squat position you can grab a
towel you can grab a shirt and grab
whatever you like fold a nice and tight
and pull it towards your upper app
working shoulders triceps we got back we
got abs
we got legs 30 seconds each no rest
three rounds all right let's go one two
three four five drop down perk up watch
there you go ankle
not as fast as you alright
buna jumping knee tucks joke ANCA okay
hug those knees right now let's do some
ABS needed leg lifts
ready ankle oh there you go alright jump
lunge with a swap lunch lunch lunch
lunch
squat lunch not block gravity tell you
what let's use the shirt make me do this
alright oh let's woo got a show-off do
it alright ready pull it nice and tight
ankle ah that's hard at it looks
vitiated
[Music]
it's good man Hellcats
[Music]
Six Pack Shortcuts
awesome stuff
[Applause]
and also men
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes
[Music]